If we replace all occurrences of Alice with no letters, then the length of the
book will decrease by five times the number of occurrences of Alice. Because
Alice has five letters. So if we calculate the length of the book with Alice
and the length of the book without Alice, and take the difference. We can
divide the difference by 5 and get the number of occurrences. So, here again,
is our book class with our new method, occurrences of Alice. First, we'll
calculate the original length and then the length after we remove all the
occurrences of Alice, by replacing Alice with an empty string. Then we return
the difference between the 2 all divided by 5. Let's add a line to our book
tester to see how many times Alice actually occurs. And if we're in the main
method again it now tells us that Alice occurs 395 times. It's not totally
clear or obvious that this will be correct, but you could check it a few ways.
For example, you could open up the text and use some other program to search
for the number of occurrences of Alice. Or you could find some word, that only
appears once. Or maybe a string of words so you can be pretty sure that it
would only occur once. And try using that to debug your code.